[Musique]
bonjour voulu comment ce deuxième
confinement ah bon et un deuxième
confinement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pour vous que vous faites livrer
sur amazon attendez faut pas croire je
lutte contre les multinationales
je commande sur amazon je redis que j'ai
perçu comme ça me rembourse
houellebecq au hip hop
[Applaudissements]
yes yes yes à evry courcouronnes ces
carrefours de evry courcouronnes dans
nadera qui joue sur les palais du pain
mais un carrefour
vous savez ce qui est très pratique dans
ce deuxième confinement c'est que on n'a
pas les enfants donc du coup bon ça
laisse plus de temps quand même pour le
télétravail 1
enfin quand j'aurai un travail
c'est pas du tout le même confinement
par rapport au premier oui à côté changé
a déjà on n'a plus le même premier
ministre
ah oui regardez avant on avait le gars
avec la tâche puis bon maintenant la
[ __ ] la tâche